Nóng Anh thì phố Hàn Nội vừa tiếp nhận chính báo của Chí Hát, Chú tại Hàn Nội,
về việc bị chiếm đặt hơn một tỷ đồng sau khi cài đặt ứng dụng giả mạo ngành địa lực.
Ngày 25 năm năm 2020, Chí Hát nhận được cuộc gọi từ một đối tượng tự sưng là cán mộ địa lực,
yêu cầu chuẩn thoá thông tin hợp đồng địa lực.
Đối tượng hướng gián chỉ tại ứng dụng NVNPC, chia sẻ quyền truy cập để thoại và quát hiện anh mặt mình vào ứng dụng.
Ngày sau các thảo tác trên, để thoại Chí Hát bất ngờ bị chào,
toàn bộ số tiền hơn một tỷ đồng trong tệ khoản bên hàng bị giúp sạch.
Công anh sẽ định đây là thủ đận lửa đạo công nghỉ cao đăng ra tăng thời gian gần đây.
Đối tượng ra rang nhân viên ngành địa, người liên cài áp giả mạo,
qua đó chiếm quyền đu khiển địa thoại và đánh các tài xả,
người dân từ đối không cài đặt ứng dụng từ các đường liên không xác mình không cũng có mạo tế bây,
thông tin cá nhân hoặc các quyền truy cập để thoại cho bất kỳ về mềm nào không so quân cốc.
Mọi thấp mắc liên quan đến sĩt vụ địa lực,
mưa ra liên lệnh lệnh hệ trực tiếp tục đại một chiến không không,
sau bởi sau chiến hoặc truy cập quép sai của chúng tâm trong soát hành tổng công vi địa lực miền bác.
khi phát hiện giấu hiệu lừa đạo,
cân báo ngay cửa quan công an để kiếp thời sử lý.